everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to me orky he's a spool yes
yeah I know
for ki is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was they pursued salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we gotta get pork a
bourbon
why am i alive
you're Bonnie's toy you are going to
help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life huh come
on hi my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody you always come in
to the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kids room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Bonnie we have to
find the totally - but what would would
he do jump out of a moving vehicle let's
go hey you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home for you
on my way whatever Lewin vanity and
beyond
kids lose their toys every day I was
made to help a child I don't remember it
being this hard wait somebody's
whispering in your ear
[Music]
you